il est resté ici et a collecté des meurtres
c'est à ce moment qu'il reflète que le
pain de favaios barbecue xv a ae
tulay joe je sais parler là car il n'y a pas
Châtiments insensés et fermés au seul seigneur
est et fermé à et toute la zone
vieille bouée juquila à son frère
garder cef
puis il a même fermé le sien avec ses collègues
J'ai fermé à xuri ensemble en paix
le site du goal chance
alors mon honneur
tu ne le mets même pas
Enrique Castillo-Renan
de travail
le Seigneur
[Applaudissements]
et laissez-les
Hé
[Chanson]
C'est
mais même pas ça
[Chanson]
congé du mont wilson silva
[Applaudissements]
et laissez-les
le jury josé do o
pivot Carl écorégion juré je sais
parler peut envoyer je pense qu'ils andré e
Jo
[Chanson]
Hé
C'est
[Chanson]